if you're already doubting have having
doubts or imposter syndrome that's you
doing self-talk in your head that you're
not the best that you're not good enough
that you're not whatever
well then maybe you should replace that
with something that says i am the best
right
so that's where i got over the like uh
is this kind of just like
you know cheesy voodoo [__] and i was
like well
no because there is self-talking
happening no matter what it's either
gonna be negative
or it's gonna be positive i might as
well actively make it positive
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
my days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back hey what's going on everyone we've
got a good episode but
before we get to it we've been releasing
these new episodes called greatest hits
they're actually
not new to the world but they might be
new to you but basically uh before we
started
doing the podcast as it is now it was
just sean interviewing a bunch of people
and we got like 20 or 30 in or he did
and
they were really good but they were
about two years ago when we launched
them and a lot of the people have done
some really interesting things
since uh or in that last two years and
so we've actually been re-releasing them
where i give an intro and
there's also sean's intro where i'll
give an update on the folks but anyway
give it a listen and when you do
uh make sure you click subscribe if
you're on itunes so if you're listening
to this on the podcast app
click subscribe and then if you're on
spotify click that follow button and the
reason why
is we're doing a bunch of these greatest
hit episodes but i'm actually the one
going in the back
and finding all these old episodes and
i'm trying to find all these interesting
stuff so in the next couple weeks we're
going to be releasing this series where
we look at some of the
the greatest predictions that we've made
as well some of the worst predictions
that we've made but we're not releasing
them entirely on a
regular cadence because i got to go and
find all of them so make sure you click
subscribe because a
you can be notified when that new
episode comes out and b it actually is
going to help us go in the rankings and
right now we're ranked like number 20
i think 20 or 19 in spotify in the
business category and the higher we go
up in rankings
the more content we can do because the
more listeners we have and well you get
the idea so just
please please please leave us review and
uh sean what are we talking about in
today's episode
okay we talk about we're going to talk
about uf the ufc the business of it as
well as
a pretty cool moment that happened in
the the recent ufc fight
um and we talked a little bit about
self-talk
which is us um something that we do both
of us do that we don't
usually talk to other we don't you don't
usually admit to doing this
and it's something that a lot of ufc
fighters do self-talk before you have to
go perform
before you go and do your thing and so
we talk about the ufc
the business of the ufc we talk about
self-talk and then we jump into some new
some ideas
sam had a great idea or met a guy who
was doing a really cool idea around
saving money on property taxes and this
is a general
class of ideas called money savers and
then we have another
another idea called the no loss lottery
that we want to talk about so
that's what today's episode is uh i
think you guys will like it um
especially the part about self-talk i
think that's going to be the most
popular part
and we did have a few technical
difficulties in this episode shawn's
internet
internet is not working so hopefully uh
you won't notice too much but if you do
sorry it's not gonna happen again
so the editors i'm sorry you're gonna
have to salvage like
five restarts uh to the listeners
hopefully it's not too bad uh we're
finishing a conversation we're having
about what we have to do um yeah we got
to select a new
i've got 89 drawings or art
clips that we've got to select and then
uh i'm having a bray you interview did
we announce in the podcast about abraham
no we didn't um a breeze leave it
unfortunately um this was kind of part
of the plan but it sucks so anyway we've
got 50 people that we've got it
sam have you had this before at the
hustle where people want to leave to go
do their own startup specifically
not like i got another job but yeah
yeah yeah most people yes um
yeah i have i always tell them i'm like
and i think abray is different because
he wasn't a full-time employee but i'm
like just so you know
like it this feels like a startup now
and it is a startup that but just so you
know like don't even
even the nice [__] that we have at the
moment don't expect any of that for a
little while
um and i'm like i always try to get them
used to it i'm like just so you know
it's gonna be
really bad for a little while this [__]
hole is shitty
wait until you start your own thing yeah
so yeah that's happened a lot although
abreu uh i think actually understands
that he's been saving money
he's been living at home and and
stashing money or living somewhere
where he has cheap rent so yeah i think
he'll i think he'll do good
we there's this thing called uh that
reed hoffman wrote his book called the
alliance
he talks about this like back in the day
people used to expect an employee
to like kind of stay with you for 20
years like that was like
people used to do that used to be the
company from start to retirement
and then that became less and less
common and now i think in tech the
average
tenure of an employee is like two years
or something like even less maybe yeah i
think facebook it's even less
so yeah so reed hoffman who was the ceo
of linkedin the founder of linkedin
he wrote this book which was like look
you gotta you can't just
uh you can't just close your eyes
pretend that's not happening you can't
get upset every time somebody leaves
that's actually the norm so
what's the right way to manage in this
in this type of
scenario and he calls it the alliance
which is a mutual understanding between
the person working with you and you
and you as the manager i actually am
very curious i want to know about this
the alliance people leaving whatever
yeah so i haven't read this book but uh
oh great great
great way to start off well i know of
the book
i understood the premise i didn't donate
90 of books that i'm
a fan of i haven't actually read and
this is one of them so
what he says is basically you need to
have like um understanding with your
the person who's working for you or
working with you that they're gonna be
there as long as this is mutually
beneficial and the expectation is that
after x number of years two
three four whatever that number is
probably not much more than that
that they may um they may leave and they
may go do their own thing and that when
that time comes you're gonna support
them and then
it's he's the way he talks about is like
he's a big believer of networks and
network effects he's like
that person when they leave your company
they're not just like sort of dead to
your company
they are now you know they should be
your champion and your advocate outside
your company
and you'll cross paths again you'll
either invest in their company
you know they may come back and work for
you later they may refer somebody in
so he describes how how to like thrive
get
given the constraint that people are
going to leave early on or in tech this
high high turnover rate
of one to two years people hopping jobs
uh which is not what ray was doing but
it just reminded me of that
yeah and i still like the problem that
i'm gonna solve for whenever i start a
company again and even now but
at least when i start from scratch i
could i could hopefully do this early on
which is basically how like
how do you build a company where someone
wants to work there for 10 years and and
i still even
even in this world where you know the
average person only works somewhere two
or four years i think it's quite
possible though
see my problem is that i like working
with and try to recruit and get the best
results from
recruiting entrepreneurial type of
people that like that's why i get along
with that's who thinks like me
that's who like works really really hard
and these like bursts
but those are like the worst people for
retention because they want to go start
their own company like that's
that's why they're entrepreneurial type
of people they're not going to be
long-term employees sort of by
definition
and so i've always sucked at the
retention side of things in that sense
um but you know i'm cool with it i think
i can just continually recruit more
people that want that experience
so before we get into some ideas for
this episode can i tell you something
that i saw recently and we're going to
bring
kind of this topic up we're going to
talk about ufc but did you watch the
rose number eunice
no is it rose now i'm a eunice yep so
there's a ufc fighter named thug rose
she
is uh like darling not like just like
in terms of like physical like what she
looks like in her attitude like darling
is like the best word i can describe her
although
she could like kill you yeah so so
the story of this is interesting right
she's she's really i don't know she's
five foot three she's
very petite she used like have you seen
her with long hair
yeah she was like beautiful two
beautiful looking girl and at
the beginning the ufc was marketing
their female fighters
like with their kind of like sex appeal
basically yeah right
they made her wear like a like a bikini
weigh-in which is just so stupid
right and some some girls leaned into it
like paige van zandt she got like a boob
job and she's like
she kind of sucks as a fighter she's
like very mediocre but she's famous and
gets paid well because
she has good like sex appeal people want
to watch her people are fans of her
there's a karate fighter called karate
hottie right that's her nickname the
karate hottie because again she's
like playing on that rose went the other
way she's a beautiful girl and they were
like oh do
you want to go do dancing with the stars
you want to like we can make you into a
star and she's like [__] that
shaved her head and was like i don't
want this whole beauty thing is a
distraction i'm actually trying to be a
martial artist
and um and that makes her great and i
think that
there's like only a few sports in the
world where the women
are equally or more popular than the men
i guess there's tennis
maybe uh maybe national soccer team i
think that's kind of
the only other one that i can think of
but in the ufc if you look at the top 10
most popular pay-per-views of all time
it's like
conor mcgregor and ronda rousey make up
like
collectively like eight of the top ten
and whenever we think of like an
amanda nunes fight i don't think like
it's a great women's fight i think this
is just awesome like
if i put it yeah i'm gonna i'm just
gonna watch this and anyway
so i think it's good that i hope i think
the whole bikini thing i think that's
[__]
that was offensive by the way [__] uh
dana white was
kind of famously uh was once stopped by
tmz and they were like
dana when will we see women fighting in
the ufc and he was like
never dude no we don't want to see
nobody wants to see girls fighting in a
cage
and um and then he like you know did a
complete 180 like to his credit
changed his mind when he when ronda
rousey came around was like okay she's a
star
i can build this whole side of the sport
around this woman and he
totally did and now it's like like you
and me both
you know when there's a great women's
fight it's just as good if not better
than the ben's heights
yes and so there was a fight we didn't
actually talk about it but it was two
weekends ago
um and this woman named rose domiunis
she's awesome
and there's this clip that i'll
i'll share again so people can just go
to my thing or somewhere to find it
but basically she's uh in like first of
all going into a cage
like you're in your underwear you're
getting watched by potentially million
plus people
um and you're like kind of fighting to
the death even if you do have someone's
gonna like stop you like the k
the likelihood that you can die
definitely i mean that exists so like
you're going in
like a life or death situation in your
underwear in front of all your friends
and family in the world
and if you fail you sort of fall back to
the bottom of the totem pole and you
have to climb back up which is fighting
a bunch of monsters along the way
and it's like in a normal sport you go
in
i'm gonna play a basketball game i'm
gonna play football game it's like i'm
gonna play the game
i hope i don't get hurt in a fight it's
like first of all it's not even called
playing you there's no play fighting
it's just
it's fighting it's actually it's not a
sport you play and the second thing is
you're definitely going to get hurt like
that's just it's not like an aberration
it's not like an
unusual thing when you get damaged uh
like you would in basketball
with fighting you're for sure gonna take
hits you're gonna you're gonna hurt
yourself a little bit
what the fighters say is like you know i
left a piece of me in that ring and what
they really
what they really mean is like in a hard
fight it's like i know that i just took
six months like that's six months off my
life i just really
i left that in that ring so it's pretty
amazing and
i mean it's weird it's it's odd but i
love it and
in this fight the camera is that they're
announcing she's fighting uh wayley was
it way lee i think her name is
yeah yeah this woman from china who's
just like a beast she's like a
terminator dude she's like
so strong just unbelievably physically
strong and again
rose doesn't look like that she doesn't
have bulging muscles
she's her neck is not like popping with
veins she looks like if you've ever
watched stranger things she looks like
the character uh things and then
they and and wait leah i love that woman
as well she's great too but
this thug rose is her name uh they zoom
in on her face and she's saying
i'm the best i'm the best i'm the best
and she's saying it over and over and
over again and
in two minutes she was the underdog she
was supposed to get her ass kicked and i
actually
would have bet that she was gonna get
her ass kicked i thought i would have
she was gonna get knocked out and within
two minutes
she did a uh front leg kick which is
already kind of weird and knocked wayley
out
and the crowd it goes wild i remember
watching it live i was like
i was in tears i was so happy i have
chills right now
just remembering it rose kicks this
woman in the head
a minute and a half in two minutes in
knocks her out we all go crazy
and at the end her husband is her
trainer or part of the training team
and he gets down at her level like
because he's like
six five and she's probably five six
five four and he looks at her face he
goes we've been saying it for years
you're the [__] best no one can
[__] with you who's the best and she
goes
i'm the best and then in the interview
with joe rogan he goes
you kept saying i'm the best and he puts
the mic to her and she goes because i am
the best
and i get i'm kind of getting uh
emotional even remembering
chills right now just while you're
shocked because i was watching it and it
was a very name
it's i don't think if you didn't watch
it if you don't if you don't follow the
ufc you probably don't give a [__] about
this
if you didn't watch it well hard to
relate i think he even if i think
if you don't watch it i don't think i
think even if you don't watch the ufc
you should go and watch this clip
because this woman she's had emotional
issues where she like has broken down
from stress
which is understandable given that like
she's fighting to death so
like fair it's just it was so
the i think the key part of this by the
way is that there's a lot of ufc
fighters who are like all bravado like
they always talk about how they're the
best i'm gonna win
i'm the best nobody can touch me i'm on
another level blah blah blah
she's not one of those people she's
ultra quiet
humble uh like a lot of people perceive
her to be like sort of mentally weak
because she's a had some issues before
and b
like she doesn't come out with that
bravado typically so that's why it was
very atypical to see this very
sort of small this gentle giant
basically like standing in the cage
facing her opponent and just muttering
to herself mouthing to herself you could
see she was telling herself before the
fight
i'm the best i'm the best and it's from
her it's not
trash talk it's not bravado it was
self-talk which is a very different
thing
she was trying to reinforce it to
herself so she would go perform and then
she performed like kind of a stunning
knockout and the way in that she
delivered the on the best line
you could tell that her coach or it must
have been her coach who
is her husband was like rose you're the
best as a matter of fact
for the next year when i ask you who's
the best you have to reply i'm the best
or i'm gonna go make you do push-ups or
run
whatever yeah or something like that and
it
it you could tell that that's how like
she was like you know like when you're
in high school and they make you carry a
football all day or like a baseball or
like in my case the running baton if you
drop it like
it's like a it's like a discipline thing
that is what happened with her you could
tell that like
if anyone said who you know who's
they're pretty good who's the best and
if she goes
she would have to say i'm the best right
and it was
interesting because as it brings back to
business and launching this stuff you
have that same doubt granted
you know you might lose money and get
embarrassed thankfully you're not going
to get your ass kicked or
killed most likely but you still need
that self-talk and
that example that minute and a half clip
is like the best example of self-talk
for normal people
do you do self-talk yourself
yeah i yeah i definitely it's a trick
question in a way because
everybody has an internal monologue
everybody's doing self-talk just in
their head
but i'm just more like do you
strategically because
a lot of people think this is like
cheesy lame like affirmations uh you
know
in the mirror and say you're beautiful
you're beautiful you're beautiful
whatever no dude it's necessary because
like so whenever you're doing anything
yeah so like um whenever i'm launching
anything or whenever i have fear like
for example even when i bought my home i
you know i don't i'm i have a
i think i have a pretty unhealthy
relationship with money i don't like
spending it because i was poor
i know what it's like to be broke and i
was like no this is normal this is
normal to feel this emotion
this is incredibly normal do it anyway
and then uh
so yeah i i do that all the time but i
try to normalize it i say this is normal
this is what i i'm supposed to feel this
way i am supposed to do it anyway so i
tell myself that all the time is that
what you do
um i don't do that but i do i have two
kind of routines that are like this that
i've probably never told anybody about
all right so
um these are i would say this one is
fairly new
um i told you kind of like i had like
this moment where i was like all right
what do i care about i'm always been a
self-improvement guy right i talk about
tony robbins has
been a big kind of like influence on me
so i have this thing on my wall
and it's basically what i wrote like
like
most people write goals like what they
want to achieve what they want to have
when i have a mansion or i want to
hit this dollar amount i want to get
promoted and for me i have a
thing that's called i wrote on it who am
i becoming and the way i do it is
because i think about myself like uh
every year is like a software update
right what's version i'm 30 i just
turned 33 what's version 33
of sean look like right and i i
literally write this out beforehand i
write out the like
the notes like oh i used to have this
bug where i got jealous about people
that's fixed you know like um hey i
added this new feature now i can play
the guitar whatever right like i
treat myself like a whole new version
upgrade anyway so
the all those little bug fixes and
features they all add up to something
what am i trying to become
and um is that kind of like a root
philosophy which is
life is not about what you achieve or
what you have it's about who you become
and so i said all right well what do i
want to become and i sort of wrote these
four things out right i said i want to
become
a person who is uh who is fit through
healthy habits i want to become a
teacher
um you know the favorite teacher of
millions of people
i want to be um you know a great family
man
who lives in a house full of love and i
have like a last one right
one more after that so anyways i have
these four things that are like
the things i want to become and i do
this thing in the morning when i like do
my kind of morning routine which is like
my reminder for the day before i go and
start just doing a bunch of work and a
bunch of tasks and
dealing with all the emails and [__]
that comes my way
i just walk in a circle in my office
which is a tiny tiny office i have like
a
i don't know eight by eight foot office
and i just walk in a circle and every
circle is
i'm basically i'm basically talking like
i'm
you know talking to myself or my own
coach
about those about those four things so
i'll say like you know
um you know i'm becoming a teacher i am
i am a teacher i'm a teacher who
millions of people uh love what i love
what i create they learn from me they're
inspired by me
i'm a teacher that means i gotta learn
every day so i have something to teach
i'm a great teacher right so i just say
in the present tense i
am this not i'm trying to become this um
and then i'll say this the next one you
know i'm a great dad
you know uh even when things are going
off the rails i'm patient
that's when i get even more patient i'm
poised i'm a great dad i'm always there
for them they know i got their back i'm
a great dad
you sound like muhammad ali exactly you
know i said i was the greatest before i
am and so so i do that
so i've been doing that now for like i
don't know probably like a year
um and i love it it's just kind of fun
for me so that's the first kind of
self-talk i do
the second kind of self-talk i do is uh
what i call revision
which is i fall off the horse a lot like
most people right like i'm
i'm trying to eat healthy and then like
[__] in the middle of the day
there's a bag of chips was there and i i
ate the bag of chips or like
you know i i say i'm gonna be a patient
dad but then like uh like i've just lost
it when
you know she wouldn't let me change her
diaper and then blah blah blah blah um
so obviously i'm not perfect and so
there so the other self-talk i do is
revision at the end of the night
i just imagine that same scenario that
happened
it only takes me 30 seconds i just think
back to that moment that i'm not proud
of
and i reimagine it in a way that i'm me
acting in a way that i'm proud of
and that's it i don't like i don't like
decide i'm going to do things
differently i don't like write it down i
don't like
um pledge to myself i'll never do this
again i just imagine it going the right
way
and then i just go to sleep and that act
of reimagining things the way you want
to see it
is a form of self-talk in my mind uh
it's just like rose
saying i'm the best and imagining
herself you know knocking out the other
girl
that's kind of what i do for you know
i'm not a fighter i just do it in my day
my daily life and the takeaway i think
should be if someone's crazy enough
to look up to you sean or look up to me
then at least now they know that someone
they look up to has like doubts and has
to do that self-talk
um the good the cool position that you
and i are in is that we
know people that are like some of them
at least in terms of financial success
which is a limited
version of success are some of the most
financially successful people in the
world
we talk to them and we know firsthand
that they're like ugh i'm so depressed i
can't do x y and z
and then in our case like we look up to
at least i do a lot of these ufc
fighters and seeing like this tough last
lady like doug rose
doing the same thing so anyway this
isn't hokey pokey this is actually
everyone has this
and it's interesting so look up that
thug rhodes video that's badass
um there's one other thing i'll put
there which is um
my trainer was big on this sort of like
not to talk so much about the
the visualization the imagination he's
always like oh you're too analytical
you're just being
like you're trying to think your way
through everything just imagine it just
don't worry about how it's gonna happen
think about what you want to have happen
and in my head i was always like
yeah yeah like at the end of the day
somebody's got to figure out how it's
going to happen that's
going to have to be me so like just
imagining it is not going to do it right
so i was kind of resistant to it up
front
but i came around when i realized one
thing which is
everybody in their head is already
imagining some outcome
so like if you're ever stressed or
worried or doubt
what is that that's your head imagining
the thing not going right not going well
failure
whatever right so if we are willing like
it
sounds kind of hokey and cheesy to
imagine things going well it's like
sort of like this hippy dippy thing to
do but the other side which is imagining
things not going well
everybody's doing all day anyways
anybody who's ever had stress or fear or
doubts
the if you just break down what that is
that's imagining things not going well
it's imagining a future where this
doesn't work
and so if you're willing to if you're
already doing and willing to imagine
things not going well you might as well
start imagining things going well also
and if you're already
doubting have having doubts or impostor
syndrome that's you doing self-talk in
your head
that you're not the best that you're not
good enough that you're not whatever
well then maybe you should replace that
with something that says i am the best
right
so that's where i got over there like uh
is this kind of just like
you know cheesy voodoo [__] and i was
like well
no because there is self-talking
happening no matter what it's either
going to be negative or it's going to be
positive i might as well actively make
it positive and if it is cheesy who
gives a [__] like
if that gives me just a slight edge then
then i'll take it
because i need everything i can get um
all right we should join then
let's really quick before we get ready
michael harris do you know who that is
no who is that michael harris uh his
name his nickname is michael lowe i
don't know what leo's from
but he founded death row records which
uh he was the he was uh
google it i i don't want to like get
this totally wrong but i believe he was
a cocaine dealer
and he went to prison uh particularly uh
i think it was san quentin for 25 years
but prior to prison he uh made close to
like 100 million dollars from selling
cocaine and he funded death row records
and he got it off the ground he's a
co-founder of death row records owned
the uh
all the originals or the masters of
everything anyway he's out of prison
he's a good friend of uh my good friend
chris it's he it's his good friend
did you go pick him up when he got out
well he he got he got he got picked up
in a bentley which is pretty funny uh
but anyway he wants to come on the pod
you want him
amazing yeah at death row who's death
row so death row was tupac or
death who was yeah so it was pock it was
uh
dre's early stuff um so
yeah it was snoop so basically this
whole like
a lot of modern rap originated because
of of death row records this whole like
amazing you know [__] the [__] the
police gangster [__] they
kind of like invented that
okay great that's gonna be awesome all
right uh you wanna talk about ufc again
or do you wanna talk about something
else let's talk about ufc but this time
we're gonna talk about the business of
ufc real quick so
the parent company that owns the ufc is
called endeavor and it never went public
and
go anytime something goes public you
know you can go and you can sort of see
the financials
and you can read the prospectus because
they have to do that in order to file
for going public so
this is the first time that the ufc's
financials kind of like saw the light of
day really
um and they've been sort of shrouded by
mystery uh
you know fighters were always wanting to
know the numbers because they want to
get paid more they feel like they're
super underpaid
um you know dana kind of talks about
numbers but like nobody could ever
verify is that how many pay-per-view
buys there were what not so i thought
it's kind of interesting so i want to
talk a little bit about endeavor and see
what you think about this so
yeah endeavor go ahead go ahead
i'll just say the two guys who are like
in charge of it i believe is ari emanuel
and i think this guy patrick whitesell
and ari
is if you ever watch entourage the
character ari gold is based off of
our emanuel and so um he's kind of like
a power player
in uh in hollywood he you know they had
their own talent agency
um then that sort of took over wme
and the dub and then they took so they
have three parts of their business one
is
agencies like wme and and others so
managing
uh hollywood talent musical talent
whatever then they have
sports businesses where they own sports
assets notably they bought the ufc but
they also own some other things they own
euro league basketball they own uh pbr
like bull racing
uh they own a bunch of like all writings
well writing sorry
um okay so so they own a couple of you
know sports assets
and then they have like kind of like a
third um you know arm to the business
which is
their events business so they have the
miss universe pageant they have new york
fashion week
they have uh they basically bought the
company that hosts the event of the
super bowl
on location so they they have all these
events and so they have these three arms
of the business
they also do publishing they do all
types of [__] like frankly
how that company even operates i don't
understand because there is some
cohesiveness but there's also a lot of
not cohesiveness
and it's incredibly confusing really i
think it's really like a roll-up
of one theme which is sports and media
entertainment so
um so they roll in all these companies
together and they have like
yeah they have like a brand licensing
thing where they have the brand for
harvard
and and the nfl and they'll go like
license it out and give revenue back to
harvard in the nfl so they went public
it's worth 18 billion dollars
uh now and uh yeah as
as of right now it's 21.3 right so it
went up just in the time of my research
here i should have bought
um they do about four to five billion
dollars a year
and specifically with the ufc i thought
this was kind of interesting so
i didn't know how much revenue the ufc
does and i was a little bit surprised to
learn that can i guess
yeah i don't know if you've seen it or
not no i haven't um i would say
uh 800 in revenue
200 in profit all right very close we're
very close on the revenue side so
here's their so
700 million 875 million and then 900
million last year
wow uh so very close on revenue but
their margins are a lot better than you
think so you were saying
um 200 million two yeah so so their
margins are about 36 percent
uh so they have 30 ebitda um on their
their product which is very good
fighters only get 20
of revenue every other major sport nfl
nba
it's closer to 50 50. i think it is 50
50 split
and so you know the fighters are sort of
right when the when they say that
they're under pain
and um and so their business is
interesting because they have media
rights
so uh guess how much the uh meteorites
sold for so
the the the uh it used to be on fox and
now it moved to espn guess how much
especially
i think it was a billion over six years
right um i don't know how many years it
is but it's 300 million a year so i
think it's actually more than a billion
so they make so the fox deal i think it
was 1.5
1.5 or five years i think wow so yeah so
it's
the fox deal was 168 million a year and
then the espn deal was 300 million a
year
and that actually paid off pretty big
because of their 900 million in revenue
300 comes from
the meteorites the rest comes from
merchandise events pay-per-view
sorry ticket sales all that good stuff
and um so i thought that was pretty
interesting pretty good business overall
much more profitable than i would have
expected given
you know all the different moving pieces
that go into it and um and
overall like kind of an incredible
business because they bought the ufc for
two million dollars like i don't know 20
something 25 years ago or something
so they bought it they bought it out of
it was going bankrupt
and dana white who's the president of
ufc
convinced his two kind of childhood
friends who were
basically the the fertitta brothers are
these like mafia family
guys who own they own a casino so they
own red rock casino and vape uh i think
um fertitta's son he they are one of the
fertitta kids or he's rh uh
listens to the podcast i don't think he
would like that if you said the air
mafia
public it's like uh it's like public
it's like well-known information uh
it's like been published everywhere and
i also think by the way
when i say mafia i'm not judging i think
that's pretty [__] cool
and i think my people in the mafia also
think being in the mafia is pretty cool
so i hope they don't get offended by
that
and if they do um you know i live in
austin you can go find me over there
so yeah right so anyways uh
the fertitta family is pretty
interesting they started casinos
they're the frank and lorenzo were the
ones who dana convinced hey let's go buy
the ufc so they bought it for two
million
and now and then they ended up selling
it and
when they bought it they pretty much
just got the cage which was probably
a 20 000 piece of equipment right and
they got the name yes the ufc they were
like we just loved that name it was such
a great name and they go we paid 2
million but we didn't really
get anything right but for some reason
we did it they had to pour in way more
money after that so it's kind of
the the easy story is bought it for 2
million sold it for 5 billion which is
obviously
amazing but there was like multiple
years
of just pouring money in and losing
money before this thing turned
around because they couldn't get
regulated in a bunch of places like john
mccain called it human [__] fighting and
you know they couldn't they couldn't get
licensed they couldn't um the business
model wasn't there they wouldn't get put
on tv that sort of thing
and um so they pulled out used something
yeah i was gonna say 65. they said in
the documentary he was like
we put a lot into it and it failed and
failed and failed and by like year six
they convinced
spike tv which i don't even know that's
a thing anymore to air
the last fighter or the ultimate fighter
yep and
there was it was forrest griffin and i
forget the other guy's name
um and they had this big fight and i
remember as a kid
but yeah i remember that fight as a kid
these guys were going at it
they looked like it was the first time
that like we thought wow they're like
athletes they're not like these guys are
they like they they're not necessarily
like thugs or like meatheads like these
guys are athletes who are fighting
and i remember watching it and right
when that episode aired
their ratings went up and they go boom
we just saved the whole company right
from that one fight well the thing with
that show is they show them in a house
it's like a reality show right they're
showing them living in a house and then
training and then competing
so it wasn't just a brutal fighting part
it was like you got to know the guys you
see their backstory you see them lying
in their bed
looking at a picture of their family
right before their training session
being like all right
this is what i'm doing it for blah blah
so people got emotionally invested
so it's similar you know like the
kardashians also like they use reality
tv
to build the brand that ends up being a
commercial brand right because you
perform an emotional connection
of you know them and their sort of
reality you know although it's quite
edited
um and then you know then you're more
likely to be a buyer in the future
so so yeah they ended up turning this
thing around kind of an amazing outcome
for them
um just a super cool business and i
would say
if you don't follow the ufc there is one
kind of like cool business lesson to
learn from it which is
dana white dana white is the most
unorthodox
president of a company that i think i've
ever seen like people think elon is kind
of like out there and he'll tweet
random stuff he's kind of unafraid
pretty bold dana makes elon
you know look like a like a you know
like an honor roll student
um dana will like so he's been involved
with the business from the from the
beginning but he will
go in the instagram comments where
somebody's you know hating on something
and he'll just be like
go [__] yourself you know like uh you
know in the press conferences
he is as much a character as any of the
fighters and the same way that vince
mcmahon did that
in wwe but that's fake that's scripted
dana does it in the unscripted format
and i had an investor tell me once um we
were talking about esports
and you know a lot of people think
esports is really interesting
space because it's you know the
viewership is really high but the
business is kind of
nascent still and people are wondering
is there a ufc like opportunity there
could you buy something today for 2
million that's going to end up being
worth 45 billion
and what this investor told me i think
is so spot on you guys
esports needs its dana white it needs
its person who's gonna take this sport
from like just the underground
and brick by brick build it into a
mainstream
brand and like take no prisoners and
like organize the whole [__] thing
along the way let me ask you this dana
white when the deal
when he sold the company he made 400
million dollars i think um i think that
was public he owned four percent of the
company
um or i forget 10
he made 400. then he probably made like
probably
he was probably getting paid 10 million
a year more than that 50 million at
least that's michael before the sale
before this
oh sorry before the sale yeah yeah so he
was wealthy ahead of time and he made
money in
a thousand who cares uh so let's just be
like conservative and say that he's
worth
600 to 700 million dollars that's
conservative i think
and like all the celebrities are one
like they like
like the the people who we think are
cool they're the ones who think dana's
cool like everyone thinks dave is cold
you know what i mean like the famous
people
dana's famous to the famous people so
he's got power he's got people want to
uh people think he's cool yeah yeah he's
got money would you trade spots with him
no his lifestyle is brutal it's brutal
absolutely
never do that dude it looks horrible he
looks like he's still like
kind of looks fit but he looks exhausted
his face is red and like he's
gained like 150 pounds since starting
this thing now it's kind of like muscle
fat but because he takes steroids and
stuff but
um no he's dude he's on like they do an
event every weekend basically
and he has to like do like he has to
manage headquarters plus
he goes to the event he does the press
conferences he's watching ringside then
he goes and talks to the fighters
afterwards and he deals with the
weigh-ins and the
oh this guy can't make it this guy got
hurt we got to find a replacement
he does that 52 weeks out of the year
and like there's a reason that dana's
not like you know
happily married at home with kids and a
great dad and you know
unstressed there's a reason that dana's
got bags under his eyes because
he chose that life and he nailed it
i would not choose that life it's not
for me yeah yeah not a chance
i i wouldn't either but but i respect
the hell out of it
i am happy what do i always say cornrows
and
and neck tattoos i'm happy they exist i
don't want them
um all right you want to do uh
you want to go and try another one oh i
didn't even see i didn't scroll down you
had the revenue down here the whole time
i never saw it
yeah oh sorry did you want to wrap up
with this or no no that's it i
i just think it was kind of interesting
i mean uh i don't really agree a major
point on like oh
good business bad business i think as
somebody who's a fan of the sport
the business side of it is just as
interesting as uh
as the actual sport itself yeah i think
that like
i think that ufc is mainstream popular
now i can't exactly tell because the
people who
like it's my sport like that's like my
it's my monday night football so i i
follow it just
as much as a hardcore football fan
follows all that
and i make my wife watch it with me now
she is actually finally into it because
she understands the story
behind it because it's basically just
wwe wrestling right
it's just like it's like fake drama
which i love so anyway uh we watched it
and
but i i think it's beyond just our crew
now i think it's like mainstream almost
like everyone knows who connor is
so a couple episodes back we talked
about business models that save you
money and they just take a percentage of
savings and how that's like the biggest
no-brainer of all time
we said taxes was good like income taxes
we said um
software savings car savings we said a
bunch of stuff that was kind of an
interesting episode i hung out with this
guy who is uh he just lives a few doors
down from me he started this company
called student loan hero you know
student loan hero
never heard of it i i don't even know
what it does it basically helps you
consolidate
debt i think so like if you have student
debt you go to their website and
you purchase some i i don't know i i
haven't had a lot of
time i think what it does is it i i've
seen models like this
i haven't looked up their website but
i've common bond is another one of these
they basically just refinance your debt
at a lower rate so they save you money
and then they basically make money
because the new lender will pay them a
fee
for the for the loan they originated for
them exactly um i just haven't had to do
that so
i i'm not exactly sure how it works
anyway he sold that company bootstrapped
it sold it for 60 million dollars
his new company is called uh what's it
called proper lot
proper lot.com and his goal i went me
and sarah went to
his house the other day for breakfast
and uh the guy just
he like i took a picture of like my like
just me in front of my house i don't
remember what i was doing i posted it
online he's like i don't want to be
creepy or anything but i think i live
like five doors down from you do you
want to hang out
uh and uh i went to his house and we
hung out and he's got this new company
called proper lot
and they're doing this but with property
taxes and what's there's a few
interesting things about this the first
thing
is that he's trying to make this kisses
theory where he thinks he can make it
makes it he thinks he can make it
relatively big like millions of dollars
in revenue
with him being the only employee so
that's what he's doing
that's interesting in itself how do they
save you money on property taxes is
there a simple explanation or no
yeah so the second is the actual
business so in where i
now live in austin your property value
goes
up every year or every two years and
then you're taxed
two percent of your property value um
because there's no income tax that's how
they get their money
so i bought my house for about one
million dollars
it's currently it went up crazy very
oddly
like it's like ah but it sucks for me
that it went up
like 20 in the first 60 days of owning
it
and now i owe two percent of like 1.2
million dollars a year in taxes so let's
just say that that's 20
22 000 or something a year in taxes that
i owe
and what proper lot does is you
tell them your address they look at the
assessed value of your neighbors and
they tell you
to the government hey this actually
isn't fair that you charged us 1.2
million
our value actually should be 1.1 million
and it all in all i it saves me about a
thousand dollars a year
and they take uh 300 of that fee
and there's a few companies in the space
but a lot of them are older uh like old
school
one's called uh i think it's called po
the url is pocono.com
uh they do about 100 million dollars a
year in revenue with 200 people and then
another one is called five stone which
is local to austin
they uh they filed 24 24 000 protests
last year and made like
four million dollars the way the company
works is what the numbers are the
average revenue per customer is about 50
to 300
and uh it usually saves customers two to
five percent of
uh an appraised value it lowers your
appraised value by two to five percent
um and they have a seventy percent
success rate so for seventy percent of
users who sign up they reduce you by
two to five percent kind of an
interesting business model and uh
i i had i don't know if you had heard of
it but i think it's great
that's pretty cool i like that a lot um
i wonder
like you know how do they need your
permission to do it so for example do
you have to sign up as a customer and
request it or can they just be like
proactively doing it and then leave a
flyer at your door hey
we you know we did this for you would
you like these
this much savings well you know it's
ready for you just claim your account
like that would be a crazy growth hack
if they could do it
yeah no um you have to sign up but that
actually would be a great marketing
scheme
gotcha okay uh cool i like this idea a
lot did you have anything you wanted
is there a riff of it uh no i just
thought it was cool no i think that's
cool the other day uh
one of our listeners jordan told me that
he was i listened to you guys just cause
you tell me cool [__] i've never heard
of
so yeah that was one of them okay
speaking of
i have a cool thing that i don't know if
you've heard of have you heard the term
no loss
lotteries no okay so this is pretty cool
so i met this guy leighton who uh is
behind this thing called pool together
so if you go to pool together.com
you can see what it is what pull
together is is it's a savings account
uh and this is in the crypto world so
it's just but but this exists everywhere
uh it's a savings account where instead
of just getting like you know if you go
to
a bank today you go get a savings
account you're gonna get .00
whatever one percent interest it's like
nothing right
so what they said and said was well what
if we pulled together
everybody's 0.01 and then we give all
that money away to one person
as a lottery winnings so so it's a
lottery where you don't have to buy
tickets and you put nothing up at risk
but you can win
very very large and so this has existed
the same model this prize-based savings
is what it's called
has existed you know for a while it's in
the u.s it's very popular in the uk
so there i think they call it premium
bonds
so in the uk there's something like 20
million people do this they they save in
premium bonds
and there's like a total of a hundred
billion dollars saved
in these prize-based saving accounts and
the way they work is exactly how i
described put your money in
every week there's a drawing or every
month there's a drawing something you
know something like that
and you can win like 25 bucks all
ranging up to a million bucks
and um and they they give it they give
that out every
every so often and so um so it's a
pretty cool model
it's a way to encourage people to save
because right now the incentive to save
is so small
so the more savings you do the more like
sort of tickets you have in the raffle
so it's a pretty cool model now these
guys supported this concept
crypto and uh there's a thing in there
in the doc check it out it's called
usage numbers
one great thing about crypto is that
everything's on the blockchain so every
app
it's like you can see their google
analytics um you know like
it's all open so i can go see that these
guys have
[__] they have 200 million in assets
under management
they have about 9 000 10 000 users uh
like active users who participate in the
thing
which is a small number of users but for
for crypto 10 000 active users just like
you know you're one of the top
uh like you know decentralized
applications you know if you're doing
that much
like if you have that many users most of
these are very very small
but it's amazing how much money they
have down there and it's and so the way
that the thing works is
they actually they give so let's say
they have 200 million in
uh in assets under management that means
their lotto is going to be of x
size you know i don't know exactly how
much it is every week but
it's pretty big and then what they do is
they roll over
some of those savings into the next
week's jackpot so they they ensure that
every week they always have uh you know
a bigger and bigger jackpot by rolling
over
a percent of this of this week into the
next so
um you'll have to what can someone
google to look at this
because these stats like the growth rate
is just like
crazy yeah so so they could just if so
the website i used to see how these uh
crypto apps
usages is called dune analytics so
d-u-n-e
analytics.com and then um and then you
can
basically we could put the whole url
there but it's dude whatever
pull together okay so i i i you
i'm trying to get out of this like oh
this is stupid
when i have right here ethereum like i'm
trying not to like even though i'm only
like 30 i'm trying not to act like a
grumpy old man whenever i hear the [__]
i'm trying
so i'm gonna try and work hard to
default to optimism here but
my question to you is this when you see
this stuff
like when you're explaining me to this
i'm like is this a gimmick
or is this real um and i'm not gonna
call it stupid
um but when you're explaining this i
think to myself
is this a gimmick or is this like
something that has longevity and can
work i mean that's like
all the all these crypto things like
many of them there's no doubt they're
cool
but are they cool like the app yo is
cool or are they cool
like this is a thing that i could see
lasting for 10 plus years
so i think that this can last this one
can last is that a fair assessment
i think it's totally the right question
to ask when it comes to crypto stuff
versus like
is there any value to this beyond
speculation right that's always the
first question with the crypto app
and then it's like okay if there is
value is this lastic value or is this a
quick fad
people are going to get tired of the
gimmick and in this case what i think
is interesting is that there's this
whole like what's happening in crypto
there's a whole parallel financial
system being built so
i have i have my wallet i have my real
bank account
and then i have my coinbase account
right i have my
my wallet in my pocket with credit cards
in it and then i have my crypto wallet
and i have my meta mask and i have
whatever right
and so i now have like two i now
participate in two financial systems in
the same way that like social networking
split it up right i had my real life
friends nearby in my neighborhood and
whatever a school
and then i had like my online friends
and i had like my online way to go chat
with people of which there's some
overlap
so the same things happen now with
finance so what does that mean that
means that there's a whole bunch of
people out there
millions of people who have who are
participating in crypto and crypto keeps
going up in price
and now they have like substantial
holdings
and when you have substantial holdings
you have two choices are you just gonna
hold it and like earn nothing off of it
are you gonna sell it so that you can
cash some of it out
or are you going to put it to work for
you or you're going to reinvest it
and what's happening is that all the
people who who have
won in the first couple waves of crypto
now have those choices and they're all
choosing to reinvest why would i sell
i'm still i'm even more bullish on
crypto right because
i kind of believe before now i made a
bunch of money well now i think this is
the greatest thing ever
um you know why would i sell i want to
take a big tax hit for selling and be
out of the game no i think there's still
room to go up so they're not going to
sell
they're not going to hold and just do
nothing with it because that seems kind
of irresponsible too right let's say you
have
six figures seven figures eight figures
worth of crypto why don't you
earn five percent a year on that money
you can
through crypto lending products and
things like that the point the point i'm
trying to get to is when you have all
this money people need something to do
with it
savings accounts is one lending is
another reinvesting into other projects
is another
and so that's what you're going to see
you're going to see all the
all the existing use like financial
infrastructure get rebuilt over here in
crypto land
and then some new [__] that didn't exist
in the real world that you can do in
crypto land will get will get built
so i think you know for that reason i
think that if it works in the uk
and 20 million people do it then i think
there's a good shot that this is going
to exist
in crypt in the crypto world it's just
so hard for me to understand
would you do it like let's say you have
like you have ethereum or whatever you
have
you have bitcoin would you put it in a
savings account
here and like potentially win the
lottery
one of these no-loss lotteries yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yes just to set it and forget it thing
you don't have to like actively do
anything once you decide that once
yes i would do that and like to all the
stuff that like
i would call silly i would also do that
stuff as well like when i buy an nft
that costs a grand yeah but not more
than a grand
like right i went like to me it's like
spending a grand on that it's just is
the same
fun as going to play blackjack for a
grand like i can totally have a thousand
dollars worth of fun
over five hours right but yes i would
use this
okay i one other idea i want to throw
through at you did you see this thing
that was posted on wait but why the blog
wait but why
called uh when he's talked about his
wife's startup
no okay you should check this out so the
guy who tim urban who writes weight but
why
posted this blog post and he says
introducing the land beep
and he got his wife yes have you seen
that
uh i was looking at it after you put it
on this doc it looks awesome
so you should go to his blog post i want
you to go there for two reasons one is i
think the idea is kind of interesting we
can talk about that
but the second is the way he tells the
story
and lays out the the case for this
product
uh for this startup is so good it's
better than 99
of startup pitches you and i hear um
because this guy's like a master
storyteller and if you want to like
think about how i should explain my
startup or explain
pitch my business go read this blog post
all right i shout out everyone who
subscribes to the podcast and sends me
proof
uh and if you send me proof uh you can
send it to
mfn at thehustle.com so that's like my
first million mfm
the hustle dot co send me proof so ready
let's get to some shout outs
and by the way everyone makes fun of me
because i don't know how to pronounce or
i can't pronounce stuff that well but i
promise you i'm trying really hard so
apologies also i'm like
reading people's twitter handles and
some of you guys have really silly
handles so
and i don't think many people could
pronounce it so give a shout out to
oh my god just this first one was
challenging job hebraican
um give a shout out to johnny jzv
uh cunning underscore druger
uh claude laudier hardly box
dave falsky jack washburn
lunatech fringe everest brady
thad warren d munga
roy brits jordan vanderhoff
oh jordan vanderhoff i think i know that
guy uh preston holland
john hagerty tx8
down david piazza wade for wireless
and the podcastition we'll do a couple
more
general comm uh kyle nydrick
loft marcus a deal mytha
and i think that's all oh my gosh am i
just
am i the worst these are really hard to
pronounce am i right
all right someone asked me to give a
shout out to genuine uh
genuinely interested podcasts that's
what it's called generally interested
podcast so shout out to them
shout out says this guy is awesome
everest brady has a power washing
business called everest power washing
dude if he's in austin i'm going to use
them uh because i need that actually now
um one rail app is a startup that we are
changing
logistics and supply chain and
democratizing and amazon style logistics
and delivery experience to retailers and
distributors
uh shout out to my youtube channel
called one man startup this actually
sounds pretty good check out one man
startup
um shout out to contemporary idiot it's
a sub stack called contemporary idiot
that's a pretty good name
and then shout out to broccoli
i think they say um they're big fans of
broccoli and they wanted me to shut up
broccoli
all right if you want to give a if you
want me to give you a shout out can you
please
subscribe to the podcast so go to
spotify or itunes whatever you use click
that blue button that says follow or
that purple button on itunes that says
subscribe
click that take a screenshot and email
it to me
mfm the hustle dot co
send me that please and i will give you
a shout out
talk soon
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i
want to i put my law in it like no days
off
on the road let's travel never looking
back